[Music]
in France it's totally legal to be naked
in public
avoir
[Music]
why don't you do your parents a favor
and base jump into a job fair at
thrill-seekers chase and he's a triple
threat he clipped dives cliff jumps and
cliff flips to throw himself off
mountains is an extreme enough he had
two trampolines and full frontal nudity
he's like an Instagram model but it
isn't it boobs so he has to risk his
life in beautiful places to be liked he
is over 58 million views and I can
guarantee every single one was a little
letdown when it didn't go horribly wrong
if being addicted to adrenaline a real
disease how come I can never find any
adrenaline junkies in the men's bathroom
offering to blow me for a roof to jump
off of if you think adrenaline feels
good he should try opioids oh that's an
addiction chase may look young but he's
actually 95 and cliff diver years so
before his inevitable death I flew him
to Hollywood where the biggest
adrenaline rush is a phone call from
Ronan Farrow in this week's ce-web-rity
profile
[Applause]
[Music]
namasté chase your journey has led e to
me come sit on the mountaintop i
specialized in teaching an
adrenaline-junkie such as yourself but
spiritual balance is as important as
actual balance thanks for having me all
right enough of this hippy
let's jump off this mofo three two chase
right where are you from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania nice you make your living
off of jumping off this that's
right how old are you 25 years old you
have any close calls
[Music]
oh honey is it worth it oh yeah I love
it
you ever been seriously injured few
times know what I saw you here your
lungs look back they filled with blood
that can't be good I wasn't that serious
alright what's the most serious injury
you've had I was in a snowboarding
competition at a compound fracture tibia
fibula bone sticking out face backwards
so when did you start filming yourself
for these big just base jumps and or
cliff dives most recently last three
years but even as a kid I took my mom's
Tamara out at time to roof and jump off
have you always been good at flipping
and stuff oh yeah I'm really comfortable
in the air left
how do you know when you need a straight
now either you hit the ground or you
just know the trampoline one you over
rotate it yes corner over a little bit
do you watch a platform diving the
Olympics it off
not so much I don't like speedos it's
weird because you're gonna take it all
the time
dude bent the salmon I didn't
[Music]
[Applause]
just cuff your balls and then shake your
legs yeah well like a salmon uh-huh
try one now the salmon normally your
preferred is to stay covered go in
headfirst without when the hands to
break is that sometimes you have to
break sometimes but very rarely the
worse seal and the better for the sample
what about testing how deep the water is
the best way is to get a bunch of guys
all swimming out there death checking
swimming down make sure there's no
debris okay rocks trees wouldn't know I
just thought you throw a pebble over yes
somebody's got to feel it out but that
doesn't do anything you can't tell how
deep it is but going the rock off
there's a depth check check the depth or
death check and this is jumping oh but
you don't want to do that yeah what's
the most beautiful place you've ever
jumped
Havasupai in the Grand Canyon it's an
Indian Reservation is a beautiful 125
foot waterfall turquoise blue water you
jump to 125
yeah with a shooter no no just into the
water this is that possible it was for
tennis shoes I blew up my asshole
oh yeah you know pink sock is good I
look it up you think you'll die
peacefully of natural causes ironically
probably you have a will prepared I've
got some stuff written down yeah oh
that's good are you worried about that
or no I'm a little worried about it but
what's the endgame what scares me
everything actually I'm scared every
time I jump but I just control that fear
I know what fear to look for what's
positive fear was negative fear and I
kind of just calculate everything and if
it's worth doing risk versus reward
how do you learn the base jump initially
you want to start off skydiving you get
a mentor you can learn from witness jump
off stuff you talk about your mentor
yeah
passed away doing a jump with you what
was that a base jump
yeah it's a base jump did he do
something wrong we added too much
complexity to the jump and we took too
long to open the chute and did you see
it holy have you jumped since yeah right
after did you feel like you had to yeah
I felt like I had to I knew I had to do
it right away
that's all I feel want to do a flip into
a pool sometimes it stings like I'll hit
my thighs but I'll get right out of the
pool and I'll try it again
what's more enjoyable baits joke and/or
cliff dive BASE jumping that one that
jumped out you don't hold it
that's when you're supposed to pull it I
was planning to do a six second delay
but with the flips I didn't really
calculate that out before you put your
get a little low with that yeah so if
that chute doesn't open that's it that's
it there's one chute one chance so crazy
because the swimming pool down there
though so you know me I want to pull it
off for any of your jumps yeah what do
they do they ask me they try to charge
me trespassing and it depends where it's
at you ever go to jail have you no
videos you say send it now do you know
Larry enticer you guys silly I'm still
gonna send it yes no you give them that
you your jumps are beautiful I'll give
it to them we'll give it to all I'd
changed it oh you'd actually say three
two and send anymore I say three twenty
three two one titties
TT's is mine no 2009 on the show we look
up titties and talks we know nothing gay
about that titties if all your friends
jumped off a bridge would you I'd be the
first to go it's a pretty cool answer
you want an adrenaline rush try Google
Roulette what's that oh it's a great
game you get trade computers with your
buddy right and then you google the
worst things you can imagine like how to
kidnap a federal judge or should i but
my neighbor's cap quickest way to
radicalize myself these are just ideas
the things you can google okay how to
dissolve your dead wife's torso an ass
and after you kill her on purpose hate
crime legality by state how to
chloroform your children what gets out
dead person smell how to discreetly
poison your neighbor's wife that was a
personal favorite of mine for Ken a
nine-year-old get pregnant
it sounds like an intend rush to me and
we've been falling for a while how deep
is the water there's no water you feel
live yet oh thank goodness I had the
worst nightmare prayers really do work
you just salmon my wife to death another
man on top of my wife I believe I just
got cooked